d'après nos statistiques en otage
occidental aux mains de l'état islamique
à 25% de chances de s'en sortir vivants
si c'est un agent 0% comment voyez vous
l'avenir de votre pays la syrie j'essaie
de travailler pour qu'ils soient moins
son
vous avez été manipulée marino j'ai
l'impression qu'on sait qui je suis il
faut que je m'éjecte très vite avant
qu'il soit trop tard il est vivant il
vole négocier deux excellentes nouvelles
pourquoi est ce qu'on veut à tout prix
récupérer malotru parce qu'il était
notre top mais pas en train de gérer une
affaire d'otages marie-jeanne c'est un
agent
une création originale canal+ le bureau
des légendes saison 3 lundi 22 mai